[Music]
2021 my knob lived up to be the savior
of 2020 as we all originally hoped it to
be but you know what at least the anime
was pretty banging
right
[Music]
this year was the year of anime that we
deserved after 2020. there was so much
great stuff that came out this year that
when picking my favorites I had to be
pretty Cutthroat in what I talked about
today or we'd be here all day B Stars 2
dragon maid 2 in Slime 2 won't be making
my list because even though I watched
them all and love them I don't have
anything interesting to say about them
other than yeah it's more the same good
[ __ ] in it Jiu Jitsu Kai Cinema and
previous anime of the Year re-zero
pretty much continued what I said about
them last year so if it was a sequel or
continuation I didn't have anything more
interesting to add it's cut but before
we get to the best shows I saw let's see
all the other amazing things that
happened for anime in 2021 hello hello
the year started off with exam an anime
that broke new records by being one of
the lowest rated anime to come out on
Mal on release an anime that had more
bugs than cyberpunk by a team that had
never worked on an anime before
to the surprise of everybody the Mage
berserk 2017 looked like violet
evergarden using animation techniques
never before seen in the history of the
medium
in summary anime of the year not to be
are done after years of radio silence
High Guardian spice dropped to stunning
praise I mean just look at this the
opening has 9 000 likes and not a single
dislike I guess everyone enjoyed it a
lot of people refused to call this anime
at all but how could you not when this
is clearly the most accurate adaptation
we've ever gotten of those early 2000s
how to draw manga books not also
forgetting we got the groundbreaking
release of the Revolutionary biopic
about the greatest gamer to ever live
redo of healer completing quests like
its final fantasy collecting chicks like
its Pokemon healing [ __ ] like his
OverWatch and for his ultimate move and
chanting dicks like it's Minecraft what
a true gamer honestly shock value aside
I would have preferred this just be a
proper hentai with full-length scenes so
I don't have to pretend to give a [ __ ]
about the writing I think it speaks
Wonders that redo tried so bad to be
offensive not even Twitter was offended
because it was so bad overall history
deleted phone YouTube holy water needed
meat let me get this straight one of the
wealthiest most powerful men in the
world is secretly a vigilante and your
plan is to Blackmail this person damn
right it is because you are black and
you are male after much anticipation
Netflix released their reimagining of
Cowboy Bebop and I mean what can I say
you got fantastic scripting straight out
of Seinfeld vicious looks just as
threatening as a Dogecoin millionaire
and I'm happy for all these cast members
getting another great acting gig what
on a sick hit Netflix show that's what
happened to John's show
from his Neverland season two thought it
would be a good idea to skip 60 odd
chapters worth of content containing one
of the most beloved arcs of the manga to
skip right to the end and kind of hope
that people just wouldn't notice
shockingly they did one piece celebrated
its 1 000th episode which is an
absolutely amazing achievement showing
that one piece fans are unmatched in
their sheer commitment to one thing
proving that they are in fact the ideal
life partner anyone could hope for
if it was actually possible for a
one-piece fan to get laid speaking of
not getting laid Evangelion fans were
finally reward
I don't know why I'm making these tricks
I'm a neighbor fan and a one-piece man
Evangelion fans were finally rewarded as
Evangelion was three plus one so anyway
as fans were given the one ending no one
ever expected
an actual [ __ ] ending yes long time
fans like myself were finally able to
say goodbye as Evangelion turns around
one last time and said good night good
morning thank you and finally how hello
hello honestly it's hard to put into
words the wave of emotion I felt
watching a franchise so dear to my heart
actually being put to rest but even so
there was something else this year that
hit me even harder every so often we
come across someone in history that's
seemingly been able to immortalize
themselves through their work someone
standing at the Pinnacle of their craft
setting the standard their fellow peers
aspire to reach an inspiring countless
others with a sphere of influence you'll
never be able to directly quantify but
you feel it someone like this doesn't
appear every day but if there is a
person out there who I think can claim
that title it's kintaro Miura
berserk is a title that should need no
introduction a manga that's constantly
at the top of everyone's favorites of
all time it's a gruesome story with some
of the most nightmarish imagery you can
find anywhere in the medium yet I can't
think of any other way to describe this
tale other than
beautiful there's a soul to berserk I
can't even begin to describe but I can
feel it emanating from every panel as
though a piece of mirror himself was
etched into every page it's something
that went beyond the medium of manga a
craft we rarely ever get to see and now
something will never be able to see the
end of
in times like these it can be easy to
lament the things that will never be
able to experience will never be able to
see Griffith's Kingdom the ancient
King's full backstory guts finding his
revenge and closing off the final
chapter of everything he's been through
but to me no matter what things will
never get the chance to see in the
future what we were lucky enough to get
the chance to Bear witness to in the
first place will always Trump that you
were able to Bear witness to a lost soul
finding purpose in life in a place he
really shouldn't have been able to you
were able to Bear witness to someone who
had found beauty in the most hellish of
places you were able to Bear witness to
one man who never gave up on life never
stopped fighting never backed down when
not a single soul would have blamed him
for doing so
you were able to Bear witness to one of
the greatest stories Ever Told
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
all right let's get to it
anime has conditioned me into thinking
every romance needs a little bit of
drama a little bit of conflict a little
bit of spice but what happens when you
present me the anime spice Master a
completely spiceless vanilla romance
about people who like each other then
end up together with Little Resistance
turns out it's pretty damn good horimia
proves that you don't need some
Complicated Love dodecahedron to have a
great anime romance the most
extraordinary thing it does is how many
unextraordinary things happen in it well
that's exactly what makes it so great
it's so casual so unbelievably real that
it's comforting you see this girl well
she heard her boyfriend was hanging out
with another girl and getting a bit
chummy I know you're thinking right
classic misunderstanding that is until
she did this one simple trick every
romance writer hates her for she asked
him about it and he explained it to her
this is some kind of Twisted joke it's
just refreshing seeing characters like
each other get together than act like
mature [ __ ] people and watching this
made me realize that you know what a
nice wholesome simple vanilla
relationship is the best thing any
person can hope for
you okay
foreign
[Music]
of some of the most decorated sci-fi
shows of all time you think it wouldn't
take this long before some exec would
have the realization of huh maybe a Star
Wars anime would be a good idea Star
Wars Visions is what happens if you give
a bunch of talented creators and Studios
the budget and Creator freedom to do
whatever they want with an IP and see if
they can deliver which they did 9
stories filled with wonderful ideas that
push the imagination of what we've seen
in the Star Wars universe and the
concert episode I'll be honest I'm not
even a Star Wars fan except for two
things Jedis and lightsaber battles and
oh boy God lightsabers that look like
katanas this chick has a lightsaber
umbrella that she uses the helicopter
into a fight this dude uses a crystal to
supercharge his lightsaber into a
rainbow super saber so he can go out
Hyper Speed while standing on the nose
over the next Wing so you can tear a
[ __ ] Star Destroyer in half the [ __ ]
had so much lightsaber porn General
Grievous had to watch it in incognito
mode Star Wars Visions is the Star Wars
I wanted Star Wars it reels you into a
corner of this amazing universe and
spits you off for the next exciting
exhilarating ride before you have a
chance to catch your breath and I really
hope we don't have to wait as long again
to see the next anime set a long time
ago in a galaxy far far away
[Music]
like a quick cash grab my gut reaction
seeing any continuation for a story
that's already clearly finished is just
stop it the original Megalo box detailed
the rise of gila's show and his journey
of winning the prestigious boxing
tournament of megalonia and by the
season ends everything was wrapped up
the character Arc was complete the plot
threads were tied up the story was over
there was nowhere left for this Tale To
Go Nomad was a sequel I didn't want or
asked for yet somehow it managed to
exceed its predecessor in just about
every way possible forget a boxing anime
with some character development this was
a character-driven drama with some
boxing in it it took the hero it had so
carefully built up and completely broke
him depression drug abuse managing grief
this is Joe in Megalo box season one and
this is Joe
post 2020 Joe's story is no longer a
simple rise to fame underdogtail it's an
introspective Saga of the fall of a hero
the inability to live up to Legacy and
the struggle for Redemption that comes
after it this is The Benchmark of how to
make a sequel to a story that's already
ended showing us there's always a new
angle to explore a new place to take a
character because there's always
something that happens after happily
ever after
Jesus Christ so I just [ __ ] quote
Shrek
[Music]
well some anime girls in 2021 saw the
tale of two waifus on the opposite side
of the spectrum I can't pick between so
I'm gonna cheat and put them in the same
place on one side we've got the cute but
quiet comey-san she's hashtag relatable
because she's a super introvert I knew
that and she has trouble speaking
because she has social anxiety I do that
which is so beautiful and good looking
that everyone respects her and wants to
be friends with her anyway
and on the other side is nagatoro
basically just a dozen character who
found herself her own anime with enough
smug energy to power the entire nation
of Switzerland before airing these were
the two anime girls that dominated every
profile picture I'd see and I thought
2021 would be the war of the anime
profile pictures where Comey Simpson
nagatoro fans would compete over which
profile picture would get clowned on the
most on the internet then out of nowhere
nft Bros appeared and went hold my
circus both of these shows follow its
own simple formula that just works
seeing comey's journey of conquering her
social anxiety just triggered this
innate desire in me to protect at all
cost but the biggest surprise was
nagatoro I thought this was only going
to appeal to the average Discord user
who has the aspiration to one day be
stepped on I mean just look at this
devious smile look at the way she's
making this guy cry look at this face
and tell me she didn't just post memes
in general the [ __ ] we're seeing the
relationship develop between the
unlikely couple was just the most
wholesome surprise of the year the smile
far exceeded the smug and I couldn't
help but get invested it's just Simple
Pure light-hearted fun and all sides of
the spectrum so what can I say except
it's wholesome what can I say except
it's awesome
Allen copper
I remember the first time watching shows
like serial experiments Lane Evangelion
fuliculia not being able to understand
anything I've watched at all yet
something about them stuck with me like
a parasite in my thoughts that I didn't
come to fully appreciate until years
after I had first watched them and I
have a feeling that sunny boy is gonna
do exactly that for me sunny boy is
easily the most overlooked anime of
2021. hell even I overlooked it until
one day I was just randomly recommended
the osc to the show on YouTube and on a
whim I gave it a listen and instantly I
just fell in love I needed to know what
this show was about
foreign
you don't watch a show because of
something concrete that you can
verbalize but because of a feeling it
gives you and I don't know how I can say
that without sounding like some
pretentious art snob but I have no other
way to describe it it's complex
multifaceted message is hidden behind a
werewolf story path steeped into realism
that I can't even begin to untangle from
the concept of death to the inner depths
of the human psyche to the nature of
life itself it's not ideas that will
immediately leave an impact on you but
ones that slowly soak and seep in over
time I'm not going to pretend I
understood everything about this anime
but I can already tell that part of it
is going to stick with me for years to
come I just finished the show a month
ago and I already feel nostalgic about
it it won't be appreciated immediately
but just give it a few years and I swear
to God this is one of those anime that
will have aged like fine wine
2021 was a year Mecca anime came back
with the Vengeance we've got to see 2D
mix again we're gonna see sequels to Old
beloved IPS we've got to see sequels to
new beloved IPS we got to see the
greatest thing to ever exist Gundam
Hathaway
hello have you been tampering with my
script again but right at the Forefront
was 86. watching 86 made me feel like I
was a new anime fan again discovering
Mecca in the mid-2000s anime boom it's
been so long since I've seen a good
old-fashioned military Mecca show you
engage old fans while introducing a
plethora of new ones to the genre right
off the bat were introduced to an Asian
at war that seems to be reminiscent to
World War II Germany so you're like oh
okay it's a story where racism bad and
indeed racism
he's bad
to raise his own no but as the show goes
on and then layers get peeled back you
start to realize there's so much more
play here the horrors of war the
corruption that comes with it and the
desperation of survival that can drive
any person to commit atrocities in the
name of Victory it constantly keeps you
guessing keeps you thinking season one
sets up the stakes sets up the drama
only to have season two shatter
everything you knew about the world it
presented this feels like a long lost
genorubuchi show from his Prime and I
hope this is just the first of many
upcoming Mecca shows that can introduce
a lot more of the current new generation
of anime fans to the genre
foreign
[Music]
if you think you can graduate from this
school without kissing my [ __ ]
you are dead wrong
[Music]
I'm just convinced Studio wits have
hacks enabled because I don't think it's
actually possible for them to make a bad
show Vivi was just a Showcase of what
happens when you have a top tier
production in every aspect take a time
travel Terminator plot line with a
badass female cyborg full-fledged Action
Hero written by the guy who wrote
re-zero with wits absolutely smurfing on
that animation and what you have is a
complete exhilarating ride from start to
finish this year was the year of anime
original shows and Vivi is the prime
example of what happens when it goes
right this felt like watching a
Hollywood Blockbuster production in
anime form and my God was it a joy to
see
[Music]
pretty much the only negative thing I
could say about it is that it does
everything great but doesn't do anything
exceedingly great animation writing
characters music this was a top
Contender for pretty much every category
while having a show or two that did a
better job in one of those aspects it's
the master of everything but Grandmaster
of none and the fact that it's number
seven is more of a testament to how
tough the competition was in the top 10
rather than how much of an all-around
Banger this series was
Souls Prepare To Cry Edition but
sometimes no amount of emotional prep
can prepare you to your eternity follows
the Journey of an immortal
shape-shifting object gaining sentience
from the people and experiences it
encounters there's a poetic Beauty in
watching something that's the furthest
thing from what you can call mortal
discovering its own Humanity from the
small pieces of everyone it meets after
watching a single episode a single Arc
you know how the series is gonna play
out you prepare for the worst with
everyone it meets but it breaks you down
anyway because it just carries this
emotional weight that pulls down on your
heart no matter how strong it is what
does it mean to live forever what is
there to be scared of When Death isn't a
fear how do you go on living when
everything around you does not two-year
eternity erects this wall around your
heart tears it down helps you build a
backup just so you can shatter it over
and over again but every time you let it
because like fushi a part of that
Journey sticks with you with every new
wall that you build for a lot of us
there is nothing more frightening than
death but to me there's something
inherently beautiful about taking a
being that cannot die and teaching it
what it means to be alive
for years now Johnny's animation has
been knocking out the door of the anime
Community for one massive hit one super
sensation and in 2021 we went wait is
this what I think it is a succulent
Chinese meal link click doesn't [ __ ]
around when it comes to introducing you
to his premise from the very first shot
we are shown the rules we are shown the
characters we understand the stakes the
curtains roll the stage is set and your
thrust head first into a super Wild Ride
the concept immediately grabs you pulls
you in and refuses to let go you'll put
on the first episode five minutes pass
and then you finish episode 5. Time
Travel is a concept that's been explored
to Helen back but it's genuinely
refreshing unaddicting when you find an
angle that hasn't been done before and
link click capitalizes on this to the
fullest I know there's gonna be that one
comment saying Hey Google this isn't
really anime and well I mean you can
watch the official Japanese anim Plex
dub if that makes you happy because I
think this is just gonna be the start of
high quality Chinese animation having
more of a presence in the anime a
community years ago I was Chinese
we get told the phrase never judge a
book by its cover time and time again
and then time and time again we go what
the [ __ ] is this stupid children's
cartoon doing my seasonal anime chart
skip on the surface ranking of Kings
looks like your typical cheesy fairy
tale of a death Prince fighting Against
All Odds to become the greatest King in
the world I mean just look at this
little munchkin what could possibly go
wrong then episode 2 comes out you see
this guy's entire Clan gets masked while
he escapes only to be rewarded by the
sight of his Dead Mother's corpse being
paraded around this guy gets to see his
dad's frozen body get crushed into mush
[ __ ] beheads a bird and is forced to
drink the blood from his head this
[ __ ] just goes ahead and chops off his
own hands clean off after a fight the
entire thing looks like a children's
storybook but the things that happen in
it can be anything but through all the
cute wholesome moments this is a mature
tale with complex multifaceted
characters that are always more than
meets the eye you got people like the
Queen Mother the typical evil stepmom
you see in every [ __ ] Disney movie
who's scheming to give her own son the
throne at any cost and except when it's
shown she just doesn't want to give the
insane pressure of becoming King to her
disabled stepson and actually loves and
cares for him as much as her real son
and you can find examples like this all
over the show as soon as you think you
know a character they'll do something
unexpected that adds an extra layer of
depth to them people with minimal lines
feel like they have a complexity to them
that most shows can't give in an entire
season even the slimiest person has
their morals even the most noble of
people can be slimy ranking of Kings is
an absolute master class in storytelling
it feels like a storybook here plays out
like a historical epic written by George
R.R Martin this could very much be an
anime of the Year 2022 in the making if
the second half follows through with
everything this first half has built up
this is an incredible show I almost Miss
myself because of my preconceptions so I
swear to God this is the last time I'll
be judging a book by its cover
[Music]
what is the stupid furry bait doing on
my seasonal anime chart
oh [ __ ] odd taxi cemented the sentiment
this year that the best shows came from
the most unlikely of places on the
surface this looks like the furthest
thing from anime of the Year Contender
material but all taxi doesn't need fancy
animation aesthetic character designs or
a big Studio budget behind it because he
has the audacity to just try and carry
itself with sheer engrossing writing
which it does well most shows fail to
absorb you in a single plot line or taxi
manages to engross you in 10 with
grounded characters and dialogue so
Punchy it'll make you sit down and go
damn
word got hands it's a show that treats
you with more of a level of respect than
I treat my best friends taste in food
there's no hand holding here you are
shown what you are needed to be shown
one scene one piece of dialogue at a
time this shot showed this item okay
this piece goes here that character
mentioned that thing okay so that piece
goes there piece by piece this puzzle
starts to unravel itself what seems like
a pool of unconnected storylines slowly
starts to form a coherent whole but the
full picture is never clear until the
very last moment where the show stands
up takes off his bathrobe and [ __ ] slaps
you faster than you can say do you want
my Rod or this Rod the climatic ending
didn't just land on two feet it did a
double twisting somersault in the
process backflipped as an encore then
bowed out to a serenade of Applause it
shows like these that just reaffirm my
faith in anime it shows me that there
are still creators out there willing to
make original provocative works of art
in an industry saturated with mediocrity
and pandering and that there is still
someone out there who is willing to take
the risk to approve it no matter how
much I'll gravitate to the 100th isakai
or the next big Shonen powerhouse it's
finding gems like these that keep me
coming back and I hope to God that they
never stop being made
[Music]
the ending of Breaking Bad the original
Star Wars Trilogy the conclusion to the
infinity War Saga I don't think in my
history of being an anime fan has it
felt like a show transcended from just
being a simple anime to a full-blown
cultural event but that's exactly what I
felt watching the final season of Attack
on Titan I went into the year thinking
the hype couldn't Peak harder than it
did at the end of season 3 but Attack on
Titan season 4 drops so hard my grandma
thought the Germans had come back it's
rare to see a series with the bulls who
attempt a story with the sheer scale and
ambition of the plot on this play here
and it's even rarer to see one that
actually manages to follow through with
it to call this season a new look would
be an understatement because until you
saw some familiar faces no one would
even blame you for thinking you put on
the wrong [ __ ] show and even then you
still probably wouldn't recognize them
Mikasa went new haircut
udis Aaron's gone from hello sir nice to
meet you too War Maria isn't the only
thing getting smashed tonight an Armin
is
finally taller than everyone else the
villains we hated are now our heroes and
the heroes we looked up to are now the
villains new characters new settings new
conflict and entirely new genre of show
and it somehow feels like this was the
only Direction the Story could have ever
gone just how seeing the evolution of
Attack on Titan from season 1 has not
just been a delight for recent shows
I've seen but one of the biggest Lights
I've had as an anime fan period
regardless of how it ends this has done
what few series will ever be able to do
and whether it lands on two feet or
Falls flat on his face this coming year
you bet your ass I'm gonna be chomping
down on that popcorn the entire way
[Music]
I don't think it's an understatement to
say that in all my years of being an
isakai fan keeping faith while wading
through the dozens of the same copy
paste shows for the last decade that
this was the show I was waiting for
mushoka tensei isn't just amazing for
Anita guy it isn't just amazing for a
fantasy it is just an amazing show it's
been such long time since I watched
something that I woke that pure childish
sense of adventure that just made me
feel like I was going on a Grand
Adventure with my friends getting
completely lost in a totally new world
the world sucks you in and immerses you
the water magic feels almost alive you
can feel the scorched air of the desert
landscape it's another world that's been
stunningly crafted and carefully brought
to life I can't begin to talk about how
good of a job the newly formed Studio
binds did you see this
foreign
yeah this is just a throwaway training
scene this bread has more care put into
it than the entirety of seven deadly
sins season 3 but it maintains this
quality through every second of its run
time the series has the best action
scenes the best dance scenes the best
subtle character moments the best bread
scenes but it goes beyond just animation
the music the cinematography the voice
acting they invented not just one but
two made-up languages for different
races of this fictional World which can
and has been translated which is
absolutely insane there's an episode
which is like 80 spoken in made-up
languages just to further immerse you in
this world Studio binds poured their
[ __ ] hearts into every single little
detail and it shows each frame has more
love and care put into it than most
anime get in an entire season but behind
this mask for craft there's also just a
real heart behind the story being told
here being a part of Rudy's long journey
of learning from his mistakes of his
previous life is just an absolute joy to
be a part of there are many things about
our protagonist that will understandably
put people off the show and look I get
it and I don't stand behind it either
because let's not forget he's this guy
but the series never lets you forget how
flawed of a guy he is and every tiny
lesson he learns every small thing he
does to change his actions for the
better just makes you want to stand up
and go yes that's it that's what I'm
talking about this isn't a show where I
found myself projecting on the main
character but instead cheering him on to
become a better person this is no longer
the self-insert isakai it's a
self-reflection isakai and I think this
is true for every single person in the
show his dad kind of an [ __ ] but
learns from it because parents are still
Human After All Eris well she's your
typical short fuse violent Cinder a
[ __ ] you've seen in every other anime
so what happens
now she knows there are times to be
patient characters learn and grow from
their mistakes everyone is on their own
personal Journey you see people flawed
people fighting to be the best person
they can be after all this time I
finally understood what isakai was meant
to be about a story that didn't just
ignore a person's previous life but used
it as a stepping stone to find the path
to a better one a series that didn't
just show you another world but made you
feel like you're a part of it this is
what I watch isakai for this is what
animation was made for and this is why a
goddamn [ __ ] love anime isekai trash
nah I only watch isakai treasure
[Music]
but anyway I've talked for far too long
already even having to cut out so many
other shows I enjoyed but didn't have
enough to say about we got it all this
year the goods the bad the ugly the
weird the Epic the funny and the
downright beautiful it's been an up and
down year for Me overall but it's been
you guys that have helped me get through
it and whether 2021 was a great year for
you or not you can't deny it it was a
pretty great year for anime
brother
[Music]
hello guys hope you're enjoying the new
year so far thank you very much this
month too Alpha Sigma basil
dysfunctional degenerate lf4 ivido Jeff
lovados manafla Payne patches pony stock
walzo and everyone else my patreon for
helping to support me for this month and
making this video possible you know what
guys before you comment I do have one
little addition I wanted to add to the
list uh because this was way longer than
a lot of my usual videos so I had to cut
some stuff out and so I wanted to give a
shout out to Arcane because I know it's
technically not anime but as much as I
loved michokotensei if Arcane was an
anime it would probably be my enemy of
the year if not it's definitely my
animation of this year and I'm sad I had
to cut it out but I didn't want to keep
you guys waiting any longer for this
video also if you enjoyed my rundown of
the top anime of this year then you'd
probably be interested in what I vote
for for the anime Wars this year and
literally as I'm recording this right
now crunch roll just released their
nominations so I'm gonna be be doing a
live stream just going through all the
nominations and picking who I'm going to
vote for that's going to be on Monday
the 24th of January so if everything
goes to plan with the schedule of this
upload that should be tomorrow or the
day after touch wood because I'm filming
this a few days before anyway that's it
from me for today hope you enjoyed the
video hope you've had a great 2021 and
let's hope 2022 treats us well I've been
gig up and I'll see you all next time